bon giorno buona sera molto bene grazie
a lei lei - we will switch to English
Galatea for me you know this is the
problem with English speakers they
always force their language on other
people so that well yeah but you know
you can find ways to you can try to
speak out the latest even if it's it's
sometimes it's true I mean although I
prefer to speak other languages the
reality is today that it's more
practical in most situations to speak
English however much we may be
politically motivated to want to speak
Esperanto or anything else
English ends up being the most practical
solution so I'm very glad to have the
opportunity to talk to you I have been
watching your activity on the Internet
and as I said in that little
presentation I made to that conference
in Moscow where where both you and
Richard made up some presentations I
remember your earliest videos where you
were sort of this is sitting in your
porch somewhere in Rome this is guy like
- and now you've kind of become the
superstar of polyglot so congratulations
it's great really great to see oh no and
I tell you I'm I'm always amazed not
that you speak Spanish well or French
well but when your accent in German and
or in Swedish or in Chinese and Russian
is just spectacular so full of
admiration how's your Japanese coming
along I have to tell the truth I'm still
struggling a little bit in the sense
that you know for me the main issue is
syntax in that regard you know forming
sentences it's not pronunciation it's
not words
it's more like syntax and when I have to
try to form more complex sentences you
know we have to put yeah I think at the
end it cetera I do speak Japanese but
I'm still struggling a little bit
because it's the first time that I try
to tackle a language with such a syntax
so it was a little bit taken aback at
the beginning now I'm doing better but
as a
always say even when you struggle you
you know I see the peak of the mountain
I see the blue sky for me the blue sky
is like you know general picture I see
the mountain but I know that I've got to
make it I'm sure I'm gonna make it
I don't know doubt that and you know
realistically as someone who lived in
Japan for nine years it takes a long
time and you know so yeah one just has
to enjoy this day to stay the course and
eventually it gets better things that
seem so strange at first eventually
because natural they eventually come
natural at the beginning I thought maybe
make him you know nothing he's just I
try to you know Japanese and you know in
other languages such as Spanish or other
languages it was relatively easy but
with Japanese even with Chinese was
thought that difficult of course it was
a little bit more complicated but with
Japanese I found more problems than the
other so I told myself you know I'm
again am I gonna make it better I told
myself you know a dear friend of mine
told me look Luca in order to speak
Japanese fluently takes a long time it's
not something that happens out of the
blue you know so I just you know I felt
relieved in a way said okay it's gonna
take me a couple you it doesn't matter
the important thing is that you enjoy it
if you enjoy it I do that exactly
what does it matter is it who you're
competing with you know so it's I found
with Japanese some of the bigger
problems were I mean with every language
at some point you feel that all the
words sound the same and then you
eventually get over that but in Japanese
that's more the case because they have
so few sounds somewhat cloudy muscari
mas you know they are at some point to
me they all sound the same
what I also found difficult in Japanese
is this sort of yeah take kuru
yeah tomorrow yeah they are guru yeah
yeah dated aku the sort of the the
second that those two part verbs where
the second one tells you the direction
and the level of politeness
you know so but I think there's more to
it for example I have to you know have
also to understand it's a very
situational language f you know we are
talking to then afternoon who you are
and
and then you have to know where you are
where you going it's it's not that easy
and sometimes you even have the problem
of foreigners learning for example
Japanese from Japanese girls and they
tend to speak like the Czech his girl
sometimes using words that are not
supposed to be pronounced and I also
heard I've never seen it for Stan but I
did have content of Japanese that you
you have to know how to act and react in
certain situations so you know like in
every language it's not just the
language in itself but it's also you
know the culture the attitude the social
behavior etc etc so you meet Europeans
we are different even with Canadians and
Americans particularly but the thing is
that with other cultures this this gap
is is more evident but it's it's fun
it's it's cool in a way you know going
and try to understand another world
right I mean I've said it for me it
wasn't so difficult because I had the
good fortune of actually living I
learned all my Japanese living in Japan
which was the only place where I've
learned the language in the country and
you but you wanted to learn it he does
ever there's so many people who live in
Japan and they don't speak the language
oh yeah I know
yeah and I think having characters is a
big advantage as well because then you
can read morning as you know I like
reading lots reading and listening and
so but anyways Japanese but you know the
interesting thing is my son who played
professional hockey in Japan for three
years he doesn't read Japanese so he
since subsequently since coming back to
Canada learnt the characters but he
learned to speak quite well just because
he was with the guys on the team but he
speaks a complete different Japanese
from what I speak I speak the Japanese
that enables me to do business and it's
much more formal yes though his is all
that serve around beer and noodles and
different I think it depends on your
experience as well it depends on the
people you connect with no the way you
speak because we're the the sum of
experiences that the people we connect
with as well as folks who read and what
we listen to so yeah okay now this
brings us to them so what
points that I'd like to discuss with you
here we are 2013 seemed soon to be 2014
you just finished saying that and I
confirm that many foreigners live in
Japan and never never learned Japanese
even though they're surrounded by the
language and I'm gonna talk a little
later about some Chinese immigrants I
know who lived here in Canada and who
don't learn English properly and here
you are in Italy or Paris or Poland or
wherever you are and you're learning
Japanese what has changed in the world
of language learning everything I would
say in the last especially in the last
20 years everything has changed you know
if you consider there is just one word
the Internet
when we think about the Internet in
general what happens is that people tend
to for example to think that it's not
easy to learn a language if you don't
live in the country or whatever excuse
the pun come up with but through with
the internet and thanks to the internet
nowadays it is possible to do an amazing
and amazing quality of things you know
it's amazing and a lot of people are not
you know I think that the last the last
step and this is a very important point
is that I noticed that a lot of people
don't know how to use the internet if
you know if you learn how to use the
internet you can cover whole areas of
language learning listening reading
speaking whatever you want around the
references it's it's it's incredible
it's just you know in the last
especially the last three years I
realize what what is point is possible
and the things that are on the internet
and there for free there there's even a
lot of resources people willing to help
it's it's my model you know but the
point is that a lot of people find
themselves in front of an ocean because
the Internet is an ocean there's so much
that you have to learn how to pick up
the right resources otherwise you get
lost what are the questions that I get
asked the most often is I'm lost but
what do I have to do to learn this I
don't know how to start with you know
this this is the main problem but then
if you learn how to select a few things
that are efficient I think that every
thing is possible no matter where you
live I would add to the Internet
is the hub but then the development of
mp3 technology I mean there's a lot of
things that go around at the mp3 player
I mean I carry in my little iPod Nano
here I've got this just blows any
University language lab out of existence
basically this beats any language lab in
the world because I can put on there
libraries of content in audio and the
first and find the text on the Internet
exactly how would you select your car
what do you do for example do you it
depends on what you know the problem is
that it is true that there's a lot there
are a lot of things but one of the
things that people ask me for example is
that well I don't understand if I listen
I don't understand right you know and to
pick up they tend to you know select
things that might interest them but
they're not able to understand right so
what I always tell them is that if you
have a script that's even better right
now
according to ie I saw a very very
interesting video recently it's in
German unfortunately there are no
English subtitles I think that hopefully
people will be able to watch it in
English he said I am Not sure he's right
but according to some recent research
listening and reading at the same time
makes you you know the information stick
your brain much more than if you just
read or you just listen now I don't know
whether it is right or not but I have to
say that this is what I do all the time
I start by listening and reading at the
beginning listening reading listening
and reading a lot mm-hmm and you know it
creates a bond between the sound and the
words you know I agree with you you know
people say well is I'm an auditory
learner or I'm a visual learner or I'm a
kinetic learner and there's a professor
in the United States whose name escapes
me who has completely debunked this
theory I mean we are all auditory or
visual you name it we need all of these
different things we may prefer to listen
or prefer to read or prefer to speak but
essentially we need to do all weather
the weather you need sixty percent of
this and thirty percent but we need them
all and I agree with you
I in the initial stage as I tend to
listen to read at the same time and then
later on because if I can listen without
reading they're not gonna listen driving
after this part making doing the dishes
I can listen while exercising so
listening is that great activity that
you can do whatever you want I think we
frozen here hello
okay okay I'll somehow splice these
together yeah so the thing about
listening on its own is that it frees up
so much that time but everything that I
listen to I I will eventually read it
and transcribe it as you know I work on
links so I'll save the words and phrases
and then I go back and I do a lot of
listening but as to what where to start
like it is amazing the resources that
you discover like in the case of check
and pick and Russian what's available on
the radio is amazing but even for
Romanian I found tremendous resources
the difficulty is to get from Ground
Zero to where you can access some of
these radio programs on history's active
sure it's not like that and there you
know of course we have a library link
but for Romanian I just went on the
Internet
there's a outsourcing sites called
Elance and i did up about two or three
hundred sentences a basic patterns why
because since therefore and I said I
want these translated into Romanian and
recorded for me and so I got those and
that was a big part of what you got
those first few months you got to work
with boring stuff to get to where you
can actually start dealing with
interesting material yeah then you
searched podcast news whatever Romanian
you know Japanese you find all kinds of
stuff
i I I think that the first three to six
months are the most difficult but once
you pass that stage you know it's it's
like a hail it goes it's easy you know
but a lot of people I think they give up
in the last in the first three it's easy
in the sense of being more fun yes but
it's still a long road it's still a long
road and of course I I agree I agree
that it's easier in the sense that to me
since
fun and since you can start using the
language Nolan listening to it it's
because you enjoyed it also go out and
talk to people I think I don't even
think about time anymore you know when
people think I I think I think a lot of
people focus too much on time they think
they should you know they they shouldn't
think okay did this 30 minutes then 45
and then I did that when you started
join something you think about and one
thing you said earlier which is so true
which perhaps is particularly the case
with Japanese but his equal to the case
with Italian and a friendship Chinese or
German or Swedish is that to achieve
fluency that big tournament high degree
of proficiency it's not just the
language of the words it's also that
familiarity with the culture you start
to have that some kind of you have to
have absorb some of those other
behavioral behavioral aspects of that
language and culture and that takes time
so that takes time but what I do and I
incorporate this in my you know my way
of learning languages has changed a
little bit is that I think that you know
human interaction is so important in
languages our communication tool it
might sound trivial but that's why it is
so I realized that all the languages
that I speak well are the languages that
I spoke the most obviously the more you
speak the better you get absolutely so
so what happened is that what people
asked me for example ow do you do that
for German for example well what
happened is that I embraced the German
culture and when I was in Rome I lived
with Germans I you know I lived my life
in German I spat I went out with Germans
I I had you know a German girlfriend and
that changes things you know hugely it's
not just about obviously I really like
you know the culture is amazing my my
favorite writer is German I love a lot
of German books and German literature so
I spent a lot I spent a lot of time with
that but finally you know you have to
make a distinction between you I think
that a lot of people are confused about
for example being c2 they talk about C -
C - C - it's it's not a matter of being
c2 or not C - or a big thing for example
you don't know a certain word your Nazi
- it's nothing to do I mean that there's
some person on the internet saying that
if you don't know how to say tie your
shoelaces or I need a monkey wrench but
you get mean it's just so silly and and
one thing you said in an interview that
I saw which was interesting someone said
well you know I have a problem figuring
out whether these words are beginner
words intermediate words or advanced
words and you said like it doesn't
matter and I agree I mean obviously it's
easier to deal with texts initially that
have a lot of high-frequency words but
if you need the word if you like the
word you're gonna learn the word like to
worry and and by the same token I mean I
may not know how to say toothbrush or
shoelace you know exactly where I can
discuss philosophy doesn't matter what's
realistic to me you know exactly so if
somebody says to you for example that
you cannot somebody asked me and I
thought I think it wasn't that Google
hangout somebody asked agree so like now
hold political discussions but you know
think about think about it Italy think
about Canada - I'll think about the
United States I think there's a you know
a layer of the population even if they
are native speakers
even if English is their native language
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
can hold conversations about topics such
as politics because they're not
interested we talk and we can talk about
things we are interested in and we live
that's as simple as that you know of
course it's true that when you live in a
foreign country for example I've been
living here for the last three years all
sorts of things have happened for
example in the apartment I have to
change the light I have to do that I
have to do that better you know when you
when you yep I call it a core but when
you when you build with the passive
you'll be interacting with people well
you know you know we search for the word
on the Internet and then you go for it
how do you say like oh I'm okay
from there you doing so right after that
day you didn't need that word so it
wasn't part of your vocabulary so I just
already five minutes ago but idea I
could even use my words I made my hands
if I wanted to you know I have an
important just in front of my eyes I
want the dish so you know with some
objects it's much easier than when you
have two one
explain to the technician that something
happened in the apartment but it's it's
it's something that you learn as we
learn in our native tongue it's exactly
the same thing it has nothing to do with
being super cool and not super cool and
academic speech or not it's it there's a
lot of confusion about this things right
now
you mentioned this thing you know you
learn the things that are of interest to
you so the whole obviously interest is
extremely important whereas you're going
to get to how this applies to teaching
languages or learning languages in the
classroom but we talked about interest
in people learning or not learning the
language when they're surrounded by the
language as in foreigner to live in
Japan I don't learn Japanese so I have a
Chinese friend here very nice guy he's
been here for seven years his son speaks
English like a Canadian he can base it
we were driving the car and we were
going to dinner and there was lots of
traffic we turned on the traffic radio
station and they told us way streets
were crowded I said how much of that do
you understand like we speak Chinese he
said like zero zero and and yet he goes
to government-sponsored language school
and he's got nothing to do he's quite
wealthy he said sir I'd like to do all
day and I keep on pushing him you know
learn and now now I'm actually gonna
start I told my gonna give you 15
minutes for half an hour a day of
English to see we can't get you
jump-started so he's interested in the
sense that like he traveled to Italy he
likes to travel he likes being outside
China he very much would like to be a
man of the world blah blah blah and he
says when he listens to English his mind
is just Tunes out but he can't do it so
so therefore I'm saying the guy's not
really interested in the language he's
interested in being fluent if somehow if
he spent ten thousand dollars and he
could now be fluent he'd be interested
but you know that's the he's not the
only one it's like that so I'd be
interested in your comments well I would
say that there are two main things that
are happening right now especially with
people living in country and not being
able to speak a language first the
psychological factor plays a huge huge
role if you if you don't believe that
you can make it first of all then
there's a psychological barrier I don't
know I don't know that person I don't
know your Chinese friend thank you
by talking to him I would the first
thing that I would try to do is to
understand the reasons why he has this
block first because as I said before in
English learning as another you know
cognitive processes the psychological
factor plays a huge role and secondly I
think they just step into this language
browned in with the wrong mentality
because when you when he you know you
think it's as exactly as you said he
wants to be fluent but he doesn't do
anything about it you know he just
thinks okay just wanted before and it's
a dream but then you know and and I
think I might be wrong here it might be
criticized for saying this but I think
that language learning is not such a
it's not as difficult as people make
language learning much more complicated
than when it actually is it's not
obviously it's a complex process in the
sensitive it takes it versus a lot of
factors involved but learning the
language even the language from I mean
learning are huge even from scratch you
don't learn it front you didn't learn it
at school I it's not because I did it
okay obviously I did it many times so I
got better which time but I can I can
prove to you by by showing you what I
did with my students I had I'm teaching
lots of people from everywhere in the
world no matter where you are if you
tell them what you don't have to tell
them what you but you show them that
they can do it and then you know do what
you like and do it according abiding
when these principles they learn
amazingly fast and much faster than any
you know they told me a lot of people
told me I'm not gonna you know quote any
side of me mean but they I went to the
school and spend I think a lot of you
know but a lot of I spent a lot of money
and I didn't succeed because they told
me well do this and they didn't give me
a guide or didn't tell me what to do and
I told them look it's much easier than
it actually looks and they when they
start doing it they realize that it's
actually true and they learn much faster
because they start believing in
themselves so you think the biggest
factor is their belief in themselves
it's not just about believing in
themselves it's a
a lot of many things for example one of
the very first things that I teach my
students is learn how to use the
Internet by doing certain things for
example learn how to select you know
resources and learn how to use them in a
very specific way then try to apply for
the principle of try to learn every
single day you know try to vary your
work just don't do don't always do the
same thing every day but just try to you
know differentiate and do something else
try to stick to the principle you know
the space-time or position whatever you
want to call it there are some things
that make it you know efficient because
just repetition repetition is great you
know but there's ways to repeat things
that make it efficient or not efficient
then people can choose whatever they
want to do that or don't I tell them try
it's a trial and error process just try
to find your way because I think it's a
personal road
honestly language learning there's not
one single recipe for everybody you have
to understand it so I can help you as a
teacher whereas as a guide I can help
you figure out what the best path for
you is once you find it bingo you've won
the war you've won the battle you know
I'm not I'm not I don't delude myself
into thinking that if I'm the teacher
who tells you exactly what you have to
do then you learn a language people
might get you know might refuse that you
know you are imposing something when
people feel like somebody's imposing
their ideas and then they tend to even
if they tell you yeah okay yeah that's
great fantastic I'm gonna file your
advice they don't do it because in the
comfort of your place they're gonna do
something else and that's that's how it
works you know no perhaps the final
question is how does all this affect
language learning in the classroom and
what is the future of language learning
in the classroom that's a very
interesting question now I believe I
believe that there are still good
teachers well no actually I believe
there are excellent teacher Emmanuel no
there are excellent teachers there are
poor teachers and an excellent teachers
liking every other field now having said
that I do believe that honestly the
classroom I think that the classroom is
not necessarily a bad thing but the
classroom makes sense just if
when you go back home you you do the
things that you have to do now
personally I have to say that the reason
why I would go to a class or a classroom
is to connect with other people you know
hey what are you doing going out but not
so much language learning but this is
this is just me you know III think that
according to the statistic I seen
recently seeing some statistics
according to which I don't know 80
percent of the people don't learn that
well in classrooms and they tend to to
think that the classrooms are not good
but we have to make a distinction there
there is high school there are specific
schools recently I was in airplane and I
met a girl she was polished and she told
me about military programs for example
there are some things institutions that
are very special and that they're very
efficient but the reason why they're
efficient is not necessarily because a
language in a you know learning in in a
classroom is necessarily better it's
just because she told me that all these
officials are extremely motivated to
learn the language because if they
remember language they can go living in
whatever it's in Poland or in Russia so
when you and also in this these military
schools you have three or four students
you're in half three four one of the
things I'm like I don't like about
classes for example is that when you
have other students they you know to me
accent is important sometimes have
people be butchery were just pronouncing
pouring you know and III want contact
with native speakers you know they need
to make it well but maybe I'm a little
bit selfish in this regard but I want to
be I want to hear the real language if
after here or I don't know another
Italian trying to pronounce something to
me it's I wouldn't call it a waste of
time because still there is a value
interacting with people seeing people
and smile etc but I think honestly I
think that if I can skip up and you know
classroom I learn fast oh yeah this is
my conclusion not saying that it's a
universal thing I think that going to a
classroom could be a good experience
especially if you want to connect with
other people but to me it's not the best
environment is to to learn form but but
given that most people aren't motivated
enough to do anything but then so then
okay so the classroom at least there's
an element of coercion you have to go
there well not necessarily in the sense
of if we talked about if we talk about
high schools that's true you know they
tell you well you have to learn Spanish
because in America is bad and for
whatever French but in other examples
people have enroll at certain schools
because they're extremely motivated for
example and then yells fall says here in
Paris a lot of a lot of foreigners I saw
because I did this test where all yell
school says and they saw a lot of
especially Japanese and Chinese people
they went there because they wanted to
live in in France so the first thing
that they did is just don't you any also
says because it you know was the remedy
you know that's the best one is the
brightest and it's the bridge
it's a friend so they went there but
they have lapsed and have what she sings
but I I don't know how much they're like
honestly I I think it's a it's a it's a
good organization I don't know any also
say so I I cannot judge but to me if I
if I were I mean if I didn't work didn't
he didn't speak French at all the first
thing that I would do before going to
France is trying to learn French for
three months before hitting France and
when you have you know a foundation of
language things are much smoother than
when you for example say go there
correctly and you have the and you think
you have the nerve thank you that you
can go to a country and learn the
language immediately out of blue it
doesn't happen like that you have to do
to put the seed in your brain okay but
that still doesn't deal with the
essential question of what the future of
the of the language classroom is and I
can give you an example here in
Vancouver we have lots of ESL schools
foreigners who come here many of them
have a significant level of English
already and they come here and they
spend $1200 a month
they spend another seven eight hundred
dollars a month to live with the family
not to mention the ticket to come over
here and they spend three months six
months and I think in many cases their
English doesn't improve very much so
those are people who haven't come here
to learn from scratch I totally agree
with you to go
the language go to the country and start
from scratch as a waste of time you
should definitely invest that time at
home but if you're gonna do it at home
you've got to have some of the
experience that you are I have about how
to do that and you have to be motivated
but even for the person who has a
certain level in the language goes to
the classroom and the classroom they do
all the role-playing and all the other
stuff that they do and the Colette's
pretend that we are on the cashier and
you're buying stuff in my store and all
this kind of stuff and at the end of it
I don't think they learn as much as you
learn in an equivalent 3-month period I
agree but I have to say at the same time
that you know talking about the future
what what's gonna happen in the next 20
years I have to say that the Internet is
changing the way people learn maybe just
but at the same time
what I noticed by talking to some people
is that they think that the only way to
learn a language ok first they think
that the only way to learn a language is
going to school and second they don't
like they don't like learning by
themselves there you need somebody you
know the older generation this is this
is what I it's by talking to people is
that they tend to think that they have
to go to school because that's that's
how they see the world that's how they
they've been you know you're used to
this kind of thing so I don't I don't
think that the schools are gonna die
because language learning is concerned
this is still going to be a lot of
institutions and there's still gonna be
a lot of people going there but I think
that you know the internet and self
learning they they can be a companion
they can be something that can always
tell people you know if you want to go
to school go to school but first and
foremost what you have to do is learn
how to learn it you know by yourself to
be self learning is extremely extremely
important you know people talking about
breaks you up with the importance of
academia or talking about certain things
I I do believe that in talking to
language learning specifically there
might be some people have never gone to
university especially people who go to
university to learn languages for
example and they end up speaking much
better because the system is you
actually in Italy you know goal there
you know go to university to learn
language you learn the literature you
learn literature you learn other things
but you know your real learning happens
somewhere else this is this is what I
would have noticed by because I talked
and I do have students went to
university they were extremely
disappointed with that system and until
we look I am trying another way they had
a courage they summed up the courage to
you know to probably different paths and
I think that people who make videos on
YouTube talking about language learning
can do a big favor because many people
are not afraid there's another
alternative and a more efficient world
or maybe not more efficient but if
there's another world that can help them
learn a late Brian different and you
know I have a feeling that we could
probably talk for another few hours on
this subject but I know that you are you
have an appointment you're going out so
I appreciate you taking the time and all
the best and so and what comes after
Japanese oh well okay good Syrian
Serbian as well and actually ty is one
of my then in my mind but yeah we'll see
what happens you know it's when you talk
about choosing a language sometimes
things just choose me yes or I could let
this beautiful girls choose me there you
go okay
no beautiful girls choose me so I have
to choose that I myself okay thank you
very much and we wrote hopefully we'll
have another opportunity to do this was
a pleasure as always
absolutely thank you bye bye